Je suis juste lié à Lou do thi Felix to do
Je viens de Cape roses et je pense que je suis un
artiste Je ne suis pas sûr d'être un artiste et un
artisan mais ce que je fais est assez difficile
à définir pour pouvoir  déterminer ce qui
est mon avec moi hé je suis dans quelque chose qui
comme si c'était un cadeau
j'ai commencé avec un plan que je ferais en
huit phases est-ce que c'est devenu
incontrôlable j'utilise ces petites
figures pour faire des visages vidéo et je sorte de
épuisé quand je pense que c'est mon temps, je veux dire que
c'est comme si cela avait été avec moi
de mal alors j'ai en quelque sorte jeté une plante
et le Podesta ce n'est pas mal pourrait être
le pire je l'ai presque déchiré comme 10
fois tu as presque déchiré  ouais j'avais l'
habitude de tout déchirer quand
je pouvais chaque fois que j'étais frustré
surtout quand j'étais fatigué j'ai vraiment
foiré avec la sculpture ma femme n'aimait pas
ça alors j'ai dû cliquer je suis devenu gourmand
avec le quand j'ai vu combien  le flic
faisait avec mon travail et je faisais
comme toi Harvey dick je suis devenu gourmand et je
pouvais juste j'ai décidé de  fais
autre chose et ça s'est bien passé je
faisais des bijoux ouais je le ferai quand
j'apprenais à concevoir mec
aurait pu m'en sortir hé et je m'y suis en quelque sorte
collé bon truc
je suis coincé ici encore une fois toi '
je suis collé au dessin oui comme si je n'étais pas
juste j'aimerais pouvoir être là-bas comme
chasser mère parcourir le monde mais je
dois m'asseoir ici juste faire ce que je fais
c'est ce qu'on attend de moi hé
parce que je pourrais vraiment faire autre chose je  Je le ferais pour le
code de justice des nouilles, mais je ne pouvais pas
vraiment m'intégrer dans leurs maisons. Je ne me suis pas
inscrit pendant un moment, puis je me suis ennuyé.
dernièrement et ils
parlent du nouveau visage d'un nouvel attar
au nouveau visage de l'art du nord et ils
montrent toujours votre point de travail euh votre travail
comme le nouveau H Christ que vous avez fait et je me
demande juste ce que vous en pensez
que vous '  re en quelque sorte être retenu est
comme cet iconoclaste cet énervé
artistes énervés hmm je ne  Ce n'est pas vraiment comme une fois que j'ai
fini ça comme une fois que tu tournes mes mains
et que je ne m'en soucie plus
parfois, quand je m'en souciais, je disais
que tu te fatiguais, tu
étais cette étagère pendant 20 ans, ils étaient
médecins du rocher mais  maintenant je ne peux pas faire ce
papier cet homme certains mètres d'hommes agréables
de pouvoir parler pour parler mais un jour vous
recommencez à sculpter je pense
et quel genre de choses avez-vous aimé
sculpter s'il vous plaît place un peu de cul
des choses abstraites quand je  commencé à faire comme
des parties du corps qui sortent de
la plus grande absorption hé ils commencent à
me dire que ça me permet de faire ça plus en
fait juste cuit et nerveux je suis
curieux que nous ayons parlé à beaucoup
de jeunes artistes et ainsi de suite  et
beaucoup d'entre eux se sentent obligés de faire une sorte d'
imagerie inuite traditionnelle comme le double
morse faire un ours dansant mais un an de travail
vous êtes toujours allé totalement à contre-
courant Wow pourquoi pensez-vous que vous êtes si
différent J'ai couru vers une femme quand  J'étais à
l'université RT et qu'est-ce qui vient d'avoir
un peu collé à ma tête comme si elle
disait que euh dinde hbu travail différent
tout le monde vous pourriez trouver votre créneau
et je pense que je l'ai fait et je n'ai jamais vraiment
ressenti la pression de la
part de qui que ce soit pour faire ce que je fais comme je  'ai
toujours été libre d'exprimer ce que je ressentais
en ce moment, mais parfois mon
travail, certaines personnes pensent qu'elles sont et
vraiment contre quelque chose qui gagne comme
les nouveaux poids Christ comme si je
prenais les églises chrétiennes
maintenant les catholiques et les protestants
aiment la façon dont ils  sorti du chemin comme
quand je lis la Bible, parfois
ils ont l'air de faire quelque chose
qu'ils ne sont pas autorisés à faire
que le camp de distribution où ma tête est venue est devenu du
papier peut-être que c'est un malentendu à
propos de je pense ouais je  pense que c'est
juste beaucoup de fois que j'ai juste quelque chose que j'ai
observé dans la communauté qui est dans le
monde et je l'ai juste mis sur tout ce qui
travaille, mais ce n'est pas quelque chose qui
vient qui me
préoccupe vraiment tellement  quelque chose que je suis monsieur je
suppose juste que c'est ça ouais pas de grand mystère
et les trucs que vous observez dans la
communauté quel genre de chose est 10
ils ils vont à l'encontre de mes croyances et si je
n'aime pas ça et je le dirai à quelqu'un
J'irai à la radio et nous le mettrons sur
papier, je suppose juste que je le mets
là-bas juste pour qu'il montre que je ne suis pas
caché ce qui est un exemple le nouveau H
Christ et des centaines de milliers ou des
milliers de sculptures  avoir fait avec les
titres à ce moment-là, je lui donnerais
ce titre mais souvent
j'oublierais ce que je pensais à ce moment-là
mais je me souviens toujours de la pièce sur laquelle j'ai
travaillé et que je ramène quand je pensais
à ce moment-là
et parfois je  pense que j'ai foiré là
j'avais tort hey hey quand j'aime vraiment
Rita pense à ce que j'ai fait
parfois il est trop tard pourrait revenir en arrière
et le changer donc je dois juste accepter
ce que j'ai fait même si c'était en ce
moment à  l'heure et le moment où vous le faites
ou pensez-vous le faites-vous pour
votre  moi-même ou pensez-vous à ce qui se
vendra parfois je fais ce que je pense se
vendrait mais la plupart du temps je vais
juste porter ce que je veux parce que je
veux le faire parce que j'aime le faire la
plupart du temps ouais un peu mauvais  des choses
comme une personne mais je veux faire ça en
ligne il y a des gens là-bas qui font des
trucs différents ici,
observez juste que
je ne peux pas être un politicien personne ne
travaillerait pour moi hé même si je sais que je
pourrais faire des vérifications positives mais
peut-être qu'avec votre art, quand les gens le voient, les
gens parlent de la façon dont cela les fait
penser différemment du Nord, ils
parlent de ce que cela leur fait ressentir
comme je l'ai dit,
je fais ça comme euh, je n'essaie pas vraiment
de faire passer un message, je gagne
juste ma vie, je transmets juste ce qui est
absurde comme je n'essaie pas de changer le
monde,
juste quelque chose que nous étions  autorisé à
faire des câbles comment est la création de choses
que nous voulons faire même  bien que
certaines voitures soient comme coincées à faire des
ours polaires ou un extra Wow, essayez de ne pas faire ça
et parfois je bourre ha horrible juste
en ce moment en ce moment tout le
tribunal maîtrisera c'est quelque chose que je
vais faire, pas vous  bien que peut-être que
parfois jusqu'à présent, nous pourrons
aller là-bas et vendre des montures gagner de l'argent
pour un changement de rythme, je mr.  mon principal
problème je ne peux pas attendre comme le flic qui est
quelqu'un pour venir à
ce bureau je vis au jour le jour en faisant
un autre pauvre Billy frustré prendre le
poids dans ma langue parfois ha bon
gars et tu es mort tu as dit que tu
aimes  chassez bien quel genre de choses
chassez-vous ici à Cape Dorset bon
boum je ne peux pas je ne peux pas t'élever un phoque
j'ai de si beaux yeux je les déteste aussi
mais quand je chasse
mais Lisa n'est pas comme l'
abattoir là-bas  Je serai dans l'un de ceux de la
Holy Smoke the die shouting aujourd'hui, nous
avons parlé à beaucoup de chasseurs lors de ce
voyage, nous portons un Clyde River à iqaluit
et beaucoup d'entre eux
disent qu'ils commencent à remarquer  les effets
du changement climatique et du réchauffement
climatique, avez-vous remarqué qu'ici à
Cape Dorset en tant que chasseur, je ne suis pas vraiment un
chasseur, mais je suppose que jusqu'à l'âge de
neuf ans, j'étais là-haut avec mes parents,
je n'ai jamais vraiment  compris pourquoi les gens
sont si préoccupés par l'avertissement global
tout d'un coup comme avant le  y ont-
ils n'ont pas observé ces choses comme je
me souviens même d'elle pendant quelques années nous
avons trop de neige et personne n'a fait de gros
choix personnel pendant trois ans covel toutes les
maisons je suppose que le temps le dit à quelqu'un
s'il vous plaît et nous ne pouvons rien y
faire  et selon certains livres,
cela n'a pas toujours été comme ça, ils
étaient des arbres ici, j'ai entendu à la télévision
hé donc les changements climatiques changent constamment
des milliers de millions d'entre vous beaucoup
de mots se frayent un chemin dans votre art
aussi pourquoi  vous pensez que c'est nous
me voyons moins ou parfois je ne peux pas le mettre à
la voiture dans notre remplissage
Sherwood apt mettre des mots là-dedans mais je
ne le fais pas pour quelqu'un d'autre avec
moi hé et pouvez-vous nous dire un peu
à propos de la façon dont vous avez commencé à faire de l'art, mon
père était en couverture, je viens de continuer ce
qu'il a fait et les dessins que je regarde se reposent
juste ça juste ça vient de se passer comme si j'avais
regardé quatre ans à jerz ce que les
gens faisaient mais le seul jour où je
viens  j'ai décidé de le faire et j'ai
pu le faire non  le corps s'est plaint ha alors j'ai continué
hé, j'ai oui comme est-ce que vous pensez déjà
après que la coopérative a acheté votre travail et
c'est après qu'il est descendu dans le sud et qu'il
fait son chemin dans des collections comme avez-
vous déjà pensé à l'art de la visière bleue quoi
ils font avec ça comment ils le présentent
pas vraiment c'est juste quelque chose que je fais
parce que je dois gagner ma vie ici maintenant
mais nous une fois je ne m'inquiète pas vraiment de
ce qui se passe là-haut et quelqu'un d'autre
fais-tu ça là-bas signifie
n'importe où et la Judée était curieuse, vous
savez, quand il y a ces conférences d'art
dans les universités ou au musée,
leur thème est toujours l'art inuit et je me
demande pour vous si vous vous voyez comme
un artiste inuit vous-même comme un
artiste canadien qui vit et travaille  dans le nord
comme comment vous définissez-vous et ce que
vous faites je ne le fais pas c'est juste quelque chose
qui aussi je pense que c'est important
parce que je ne fais pas ça une seconde
je le faisais pour l'art mais
c'est devenu  autre chose qu'est-ce que
c'était  est venu quelque chose que je dois lui
faire vivre avec ça faire mes enfants et
plaire à ma femme
mais pensez-vous que le genre de travail que vous faites
devrait être dans des galeries
spécialisées dans l'art moderne et l'
art abstrait ou devrait-il être dans des galeries
spécialisées  entre guillemets l'art inuit
que je ne m'inquiète pas pour ça
en fait je n'aime pas les
galeries hé là les plus gourmands mais
deux personnes sur cette planète je ne sais
pas pourquoi ils s'en moqueront  bien bien avec
nous, je veux dire, c'est nous qui proposons le
matériel de ce jour, mais je n'ai jamais
compris pourquoi j'ai attendu que nous en arrivions
financièrement, est-ce que vous avez l'impression que le
monde de l'art vous comprend mal, vous et votre
travail, ah je ne  Je m'en fous vraiment de ce que ce
monde d'accord cool quoi qu'il en soit au sein de la
compagnie Je m'en fiche Je sais pourquoi je pense que
je dois l'isoler
cette question de fait je préfère cela sur le
dessus en un jour je ne connais pas de très
bonnes compétences interpersonnelles
je  J'avais des plans pour ça mais ils ont tous
échoué j'allais faire l'air de
ces deux petites minutes la charité
prendra pour toujours la serviette s'aggrave pendant ce temps je
dois manger si je prends trop de temps ça
vient comme sans valeur ne vaut pas mon temps
même si atari  genre sans valeur maintenant
c'est pire je suis inquiet mais le couple
de ces trucs parce que la connexion met
des tables de pincement de pain ce que les temps ont un
bon je dois le faire aussi
et cette pièce est-elle presque terminée ou nous
avons encore beaucoup de travail à faire c'est
presque fini bébé je pense bien je
n'avais jamais vraiment jamais vraiment fini c'est
fait plus qu'étiré parfois tu
dis travaillé dessus demain comme cet
exemple je peux travailler sur un dessin pendant des
années et des années et tout dépend je
suppose que certaines personnes et quelles
personnes  finir par faire je ne serai pas j'ai en quelque sorte
vu que quand je faisais des bijoux, ai-je
quand les travaux d'oreille sont en fait choisis pour
la collection d'imprimés cape dorset comment
vous sentez-vous je viens de commencer comme l'
année dernière je pense que je n'ai pas vraiment  y a eu une
chance mais nu H Christ par exemple
qui était dans la collecte de 2008 oui
bon qu'un genre s'est enfui comme je l'ai enseigné
je pensais essayer d'arrêter et de
planifier j'ai commencé j'ai arrêté
quelques innocence ici  Je n'aime pas la façon dont
ils allaient tout cela
pensez-vous que la collection d'imprimés cape dorset
va survivre au
cours des 50 prochaines années nous avons eu le 50e
anniversaire l'année dernière est-ce qu'elle va
survivre pendant encore 50 ans j'espère alors
comment
selon les invités, le marché mondial ou
quelque chose du genre a baissé, mais ensuite nous avons planté
des costumes de crise d'octobre,
la ville est morte lorsque le marché mondial
s'est effondré, même si ce qui se passe maintenant,
cela nous affecte, vous voulez dire que moins de gens l'
achètent, ont léché un divorce et
tout  qu'alors je cogne autant alors nous nous sommes
coincés je suppose que nous avons demandé cela quand
nous avons pris un nouveau numéro, nous sommes sous un
parapluie pendant des années et des années en sécurité sur le
monde extérieur ha et nous n'avions aucune idée de
ce qui se passe là-bas la plupart d'entre nous ne '  t ragoût
qui est nous  vous savez chez les gens frères
ça a toujours été nous et puis qui que ce
soit qui est eux et Bray là-bas vous la
pose résolue et curieuse est-ce que vos enfants
seront des artistes comme vous je ne
veux pas qu'ils aient une vie difficile je préfère
J'ai travaillé quand je viens mon
nez que feriez-vous si l'un de vos
enfants qu'ils voulaient absolument être
un artiste que pourrais-je faire ce serait
quelque chose comme ses enfants
vous